what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some fantastic four
in the marvel cinematic universe rumors
to go over with the release of
one division the falcon and the winter
soldier and of course the upcoming
spider-man 3 film
no way home things are extremely
exciting right now in the mcu but
let's not forget about what is coming
and only a few months ago at disney's
investor day kevin feige announced that
we
are indeed getting a fantastic four
movie relatively soon
but what he specifically said that you
need to know which you probably already
do
is that they are currently working on
the fantastic four
feature meaning they have started with
the fantastic four it is in
pre-production
and today we have some casting rumors
and rumors about the actual plot leak of
what's going to happen in the fantastic
four film
and i'll break it all down for you but
first if you would like to enter the
giveaway for a chance to win
a captain america shield from the falcon
and the winter soldier be sure to check
out the rules in the description down
below i'm doing two giveaways one on
youtube and one on instagram
subscribe to my channel and subscribe to
taya miller i'll put the link in the
description down below
so first things first we'll talk about
the casting for the fantastic
four the fan favorites right now are of
course john krasinski as
reed richards aka mr fantastic and his
wife
in real life emily blunt to play the
role of his wife in the movie
sue storm aka the invisible woman these
are the fan favorites by far
however it's looking like we may not get
them
as the characters not too long ago maybe
a month or so ago there was a rumor
going around that jennifer lawrence
could be in the running to play sue
storm slash the invisible
woman then after this rumor came out she
was apparently spotted in sydney
australia where they are shooting thor
love and thunder
now it doesn't really make any sense for
sue storm or any of the fantastic four
to appear
in thor love and thunder so everybody
thought well maybe she's filming a scene
for thor love and thunder and she's a
character in that film
perhaps enchantress but it was then
realized that she could actually be
shooting
a post-credits scene a post-credit scene
for thor love and thunder that could
introduce
sue storm and set up the fantastic four
movie because we know that movie is
going to be coming out after thor love
and thunder
now the reason i'm talking about these
rumors that happened a month ago or so
is because of the rumors that are
happening right now new reports and
rumors from small screen and
geekositymac.com state that emily blunt
is no longer in the runs to play
sue storm however this is not because
marvel did not want her
according to small screen emily blunt
wasn't interested in such an extensive
arrangement
edward lotter of small screen explains
it seems as though she just wasn't
comfortable signing a multiple picture
deal with marvel studios due to the
level of her commitment they wanted from
her
emily blunt and john krasinski have two
children together and our source
informed us that blunt didn't think it
would be a good idea to be moving the
family around in order to star in these
marvel movies
and this could very well be the case the
fantastic four aren't going to be
just small characters they introduce for
one movie or two they're going to be
like
iron man and captain america and thor
they're going to get their own movies
but they're also going to pop up in
other team projects as well
then not to mention the projects where
you're going to bring the fantastic four
together with the avengers
and the x-men this will be an insanely
huge project that won't take place for a
while
many years after the first introduction
of the fantastic four
so it is quite a commitment to play a
character in the mcu
and if you have small children at home i
can see how that could be really hard on
an actress however it doesn't really say
much about her husband john krasinski
john krasinski is apparently still in
the running to play mr fantastic
and we do know that at some point in
time last year he did have a zoom call
with people at marvel so he could very
well
already be in negotiations since kevin
feige said they're currently working on
the feature that means casting has to be
done
pretty soon along with the story and the
script
and as i mentioned we have some rumors
about what might happen
in the movie now like i said it's a
rumor nothing is confirmed here but the
rumors actually sound pretty exciting
now it starts off by saying that the
fantastic four will make their first
appearance in ant-man quantum mania
this is something that fans have been
predicting for a pretty long time
instead of the fantastic four going into
space and getting their powers the
traditional way
they could actually go into the quantum
realm get stuck
somehow and that's how they get their
powers this would very much be like
janet van dyne she got stuck inside of
the quantum realm for many many years
and when she came out she said that she
evolved she developed some type of
powers so this would be a very
interesting way to give them their
powers and kind of do a different story
it goes on to say that this film is
going to address the origin of the team
as we would hope it would reed richards
is a brilliant scientist from pym
technologies who found out from darren
cross about pym particles and decided to
study them
he has his own lab at home and kept his
advancement of his studies a secret
until he discovers the quantum realm
already married to sue storm they both
work together to further study the
quantum realm and discover that it is
possible to access it
through the particles and they decide to
try and go there developing their own
methods with the help of johnny sue's
brother and
ben reed's best friend in a secret
experiment at pym technologies
everything goes wrong and they end up in
the quantum realm in the 2010s
fearing that pym will find out darren
hides everything from hank pym and
erases the data about that event
trapping them in the quantum realm
without anybody knowing that they're
there
however it all comes to light when in
quantum mania
scott lang and hope van dime have some
type of call or
signal from the quantum realm now i know
this is a rumor but this part right here
actually sounds pretty dang good
this would already give them deep ties
to the mcu and things that have already
happened
and it would give them a pretty big
connection to hank pym not to mention
it's a pretty fresh take on the story
and we have to keep in mind that the
story of the fantastic four has already
been told on screen a few times now
and of course fans haven't exactly been
too excited about what they saw on
screen recently so the fact that they
might take a different approach with the
fantastic four
is probably a very good idea now this
says that victor von doom
will be in the film as a millionaire
scientist friend of reed but not
yet as dr doom it also says that this
film will take place
right after the events of secret
invasion and the film is based on the
team dealing with a new world
and adapting to technologies while a
clash between humans and scrolls
is ongoing and the last fun part about
this rumor is it says that tom holland
spider-man could also make an appearance
and this is something that a lot of
people
really really want because in the comics
the human torch and spider-man are
really really good friends
they have an awesome relationship and it
would be really cool to see on screen
not to mention the fantastic four easter
eggs that we got in spider-man far from
home
the new avengers tower under
construction could it possibly go on to
become
the baxter building or maybe doom's
building but right outside that building
is a sign that says we are so excited to
show you
what comes next and then it says one two
three and then a
question mark so perhaps spider-man
could make an appearance in the
fantastic four movie we could get the
relationship between peter parker and
johnny storm and this could indeed
go on to become the baxter building
which i think everybody would be
really really excited about and the last
thing i'll say about this rumor is it
says that reed richards and sue storm
are already
married which is definitely a different
take than the other movies that we've
seen before and again marvel studios is
going to want to go down a different
route
than we've already seen so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news that is it for our fantastic
four rumors today
let me know what you think about them in
the comments down below and let me know
who you think would play
a good sioux storm slash the invisible
woman in the marvel cinematic universe
let me know down below also don't forget
to check the details about the giveaway
in the description down below as well
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you